God of War Ragnarok reviews are here a
tease at a second war zone 2.0 map and
Modern Warfare 2 gets its first
post-launch patch all this on today's
Gamespot news
Ragnarok reviews are here and it sounds
like the game ragnaroks look I'm sorry I
tried to write the script and not make a
joke but I just couldn't do it I promise
it's the only one on Metacritic which
full disclosure is a sister site to
Gamespot the game at the time of
recording has a 94 average based on 112
reviews that is the exact same score its
2018 predecessor has on the site as well
based on 118 reviews our own review from
Timor Hussein States quote God of War
Ragnarok is a lavish production with
pristine visuals draw dropping scale
crunchy combat that is as satisfying as
it is brutal and a world that begs to
have its every corner and crevice
explored Hussein's singular gripe with
the game stems from elements of its
combat noting quote the mechanics can
struggle under the pressure of the
increased speed and aggression as the
game progresses Leon Hurley at Games
Radar has some light criticism of the
game's first half saying quote I found
God of War Ragnarok an oddly split
experience overall there's a light start
that feels padded still good but missing
depth which leads into a weighty finish
that's every bit the equal of its
predecessor game informers Kyle Hilliard
who used to be gamespot's Kyle Hilliard
they won him over by saying he could
review Ragnarok I'm sure writes quote
God of War Ragnarok feels a lot like God
of War 2018 which is a compliment
considering how fantastic that game is
Sony Santa Monica was right to not break
what wasn't broken and it has expertly
continued the story threads that were
left hanging from the previous game any
complaints about the overall experience
familiar combat collecting and leveling
up equipment isn't particularly
interesting are quickly forgotten in the
face of the compelling narrative
believable character relationships and
incredible visuals and animation not too
bad in a rock look I'm sorry I lied to
you about that only being one joking
wasn't cool what is cool is that we
might already know what our next Warzone
2.0 map is after almazra launches with
the free-to-play game mode on November
16th following reports that a second
Warzone 2.0 map was already in
development an eagle-eyed player noticed
in the Modern Warfare 2 campaign mission
El SI nombre a map of the location Las
Almas is present that reportedly looks
strikingly similar in terms of design to
a concept art map that the website
inside a gaming saw of al-masra before
its announcement as Warzone 2.0's Launch
map inside a gaming also states that
sources confirmed that one of the maps
for the upcoming escape from tarkov ask
DMZ mode of which there are rumored to
before would double up as a war zone map
considering that Los Almas is just as
integral if not more so to the story in
Modern Warfare 2 as al-masra there's an
extreme likelihood that the fictional
Mexican city will serve as a local
education in the future of War Zone but
that is so far off you want to know
what's happening with Call of Duty today
and thankfully what is happening with
the game right now is it has gotten its
first patch making a number of Welcome
changes the new patch fixes an issue
that previously stopped players from
being able to edit their profile
showcase what's more the patch addresses
quote various map exploits and bugs from
across the title and that is it for
today's Gamespot news to those God of
War Ragnarok reviews get you excited for
the game what issues in Modern Warfare 2
have you seen that you hope Infinity
Ward addresses let us know in the
comments below and we'll see you here
tomorrow for more Gamespot news
[Music]
foreign
[Music]